ce soir une enquête sur le monde
mystérieux des clients des avions
d'affaires de bombardier et c'est
celle-là vente d'avions de luxe est par
définition une sale affaire un monde de
personnages troubles ou bombardier misé
gros ciseaux vendres réflexion sur
l'éthique il anticiperait les
conséquences en juin dernier à genève
bombardier a lancé en grande pompe le
dernier né de la famille global parce
que depuis qu'il a cédé le contrôle de
la cseries à airbus la multinationale
québécoise a décidé que son avenir
passait plus que jamais par les avions
d'affaires y compris dans des pays où la
corruption est endémique et où l'origine
de certaines fortunes est douteuse
l'avion bombardier ait disparu personne
mandat d'arrêt a été émis contre un des
frères coupe 3 au 13 avril 2018
un avion d'affaires de bombardier se
pose en afrique du sud en pleine
controverse l'avion financer avec de
l'argent canadien était disparue depuis
plusieurs semaines sa balise gps
déconnecté à par l'équipage
il n'y a personne à bord les
propriétaires ceux à qui bombarde et
avait vendu cet avion trois ans plus tôt
se sont enfuis du pays
une scène mystérieuse qui a mené
plusieurs à se demander comment la
multinationale québécoise choisi ses
clientes
lorsqu'elles vendent des appareils si
luxueux
pour mieux comprendre
nous nous sommes rendus à ibb et à
genève en suisse
l'un des plus importants salon de
l'aviation d'affaires canapé champagne
caviar
ici on ne lésine pas sur les moyens pour
séduire les acheteurs potentiels
ils viennent de partout sur la planète
et circulent sur le tarmac comme si
c'était un soir de première
il visite les appareils avec leurs
vêtements griffés certains sans même
enlever leurs verres fumés notamment
qu'il ya des machines exceptionnelles
la scène qui nous allons voir dans cinq
minutes il est plus verte juste en face
pourquoi plus belle qu'elle est presque
l'intérieur avait tout à fait
exceptionnel
ce qu'on parle pas ici de simples avions
plutôt dire des villas volante qui peut
vous conduire dans les plus beaux
endroits du monde
l'équipage est l'avion vous attendent en
permanence et ils sont prêts à décoller
quand vous avez besoin de quoi vous
finissez votre réunion sauter dans
l'avion et c'est parti vous arriver
reposé et vous continuez votre travail
dans ce monde de luxe et d'opulence
bombardier est un grand joueur c'est la
compagnie qui vend le plus d'avions
d'affaires en une année l'entreprise
québécoise à toute une gamme d'appareils
des petits learjet en passant par les
challengers jusqu'au dernier né les
nouveaux globale du global 6000 de
bombardier on est dans un avion
d'affaires qui avaient les plus haut de
gamme sur le marché un avion qu'une
distance franchissable 6000 milles
nautiques ton peut faire l'émission à
partir de montréal jusqu'au au moyen
orient par exemple jusqu'à la voirie
photo ea mobile en cuir finition des
cabines en bois comptoirs de granit dans
la salle de bains douches italiennes
grandes chambres fermées cuisine moderne
salon et bureaux équipés d'internet
haute vitesse et tout peut être fait sur
mesure
c'est simple le design et le confort
dans ces avions sont aussi relevé sinon
plus qu'une résidence moyenne un
africain qu'on vend aujourd'hui on peut
payer combien plus basé autour de 60
millions de dollars américains pour vous
donner de la visibilité et faire vendre
ses global
bombardier a mis le paquet à ebay ce son
kiosque est probablement le plus visible
c'est la porte d'entrée de bombardier
vers de nouveaux horizons
ici par exemple un genève on importe nos
vendeurs qui sont basés en europe au
moyen orient en afrique et en asie pour
avoir pour avoir la meilleure
opportunité de parler directement aux
clients mais les discussions et les
signatures de contrats se font loin et
des regards du public
alors qui sont ces clients youssouf des
individus fortunés des vip des gens
assez riche pour se payer ses
magnifiques jouets
antonia lukacs innova gravitent dans
l'univers de l'aviation d'affaires
depuis quelques années elle publie un
livre dans lequel elle recense les
différents appareils
la majeure partie des propriétaires
d'avions sont des entrepreneurs qui
doivent sauver du temps
il y a aussi les vip et les vedettes et
finalement les politiciens qui ont
besoin de se déplacer pour les affaires
de l'état
vendre des avions d'affaires à des
politiciens ou à des gens qui ont des
liens étroits avec eux n'est pas sans
risque selon le journaliste witcher pop
lac qui a fait enquête sur les avions
privés en afrique comme pour les
individus très fortunés l'achat d'un jet
privé devient davantage manoeuvre
astucieuse qu'un geste ostentatoire
parce que ça leur permet de cacher leurs
achats sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de
genève
bombardier et ses concurrents tentent de
séduire des clients qui proviennent des
quatre coins du globe
mais ici à ibb s il y à un éléphant dans
la pièce d'où vient l'argent pour payer
ses palaces volants les panama et
paradise papers ses immenses fuites de
documents qui ont mis au jour des
stratagèmes d'utilisation des paradis
fiscaux contiennent des centaines de
documents sur des transactions entre
bombardier et des clients qui se cache
derrière de complexes structures
offshore wind sais je dirais que par
définition vendre des avions luxueux est
une sale affaire parce qu'on essaie
désespérément de vendre ses produits de
luxe à de riches individus qui n'ont pas
toujours fait fortune de façon légale
kane the wolf man est l'un des clients
de bombardier qui a attiré notre
attention bien du nigeria un pays classé
parmi les plus corrompus de la planète
joseph à vous mais mu qui dit johnson en
juin 2013
monsieur johnson et président dary caire
le principal transporteur aérien et du
nigeria quand il sait mieux contrat avec
bombardier
l'organisation québécoise souligne le
coût sans ménagement friday marque du
chan
poli mais celui qu'on applaudit
chaleureusement est loin d'être un
client sans tache
à l'époque monsieur johnson a déjà fait
l'objet d' enquête de la commission
nigériane contre les délits économiques
et financiers
son nom apparaît notamment dans des
allégations de détournement de fonds
publics de l'ordre de 500 millions de
dollars américains
une affaire qui remonte à 2007 et dont
on ne connaît toujours pas les
conclusions
ça n'empêche pas bombardier de vendre
personnellement et plus discrètement à
monsieur johnson deux jets d'affaires
pour un total de 75 millions de dollars
américains à travers deux entités
offshore ne vendent pas des chandails à
15 dollars en vendre des avions qui
valent des millions de dollars donc la
relation d'affaires elle est à long
terme et les peaux du repos 15 minutes
et donc on entre en affaires on connaît
en temps on se doit de connaître un peu
plus on veut on veut surtout pas
s'exposer à être liés de près ou de loin
à des individus ou des groupes qui
auraient par exemple qui ferait l'objet
par exemple d'autres de soupçons
pourtant parmi les documents liés au
financement des deux avions privés
un rapport indique clairement qu'il est
risqué de faire affaire avec monsieur
johnson on y voit plusieurs drapeaux
rouges
un autre rapport identifie monsieur
johnson comme un individu à haut risque
la conséquence est une responsabilité
morale et les entreprises ont peuvent
payer le prix cher au niveau de leur
réputation
bombardier refuse de dire si elle a pris
connaissance de ces informations
et ne commente pas le cas de monsieur
johnson par souci de confidentialité
mais de façon générale la multinationale
affirme faire des vérifications
diligentes pour tous ses clients
est ce que bombardier ce sens la
responsabilité de vérifier d'anchois ses
clients de vérifier qu'ils sont
l'origine de leur fortune
on suit un processus pour chaque avion
donc on ne vendrai jamais un avion à
quelqu'un qui ne reflète pas les idéaux
que nous nous voulons représenter les
citoyens ne supporte plus
l'irresponsabilité avec laquelle
agissent un certain nombre de
multinationales
l'avocat français william bourdon a
fondé le ng sherpa qui s'est spécialisé
dans la traque des biens de luxe des
dirigeants corrompus ou leur entourage
il apaise la les biens mal acquis comme
ici à paris
il a réussi à récupérer de façon
spectaculaire
ceux d'un dirigeant africain en plein
centre de la capitale française
moi j'ai eu l'intuition il ya dix ans
que tous ses biens immobiliers et
mobiliers n'avait pas été acquis par la
grâce du saint-esprit en jouant au
casino ou par la générosité d'une
vieille tante américaine sphère
économique depuis nombreuses années
william bourdon qui dénoncent la
corruption sur toutes les tribunes
estime que bombarder manque de vigilance
au mieux c'est de la naïveté et une
imprudence et au pire c'est à cynisme
récurrent répété dans une logique je
répète de pas vu pas pris avec cette
conviction que de toute façon personne
n'arrivera à vous rendre de wable
après la pause des clients contreversé
reviennent hanter bombardier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais 2013 à sans citer un méga complexe
touristique sud africains se déroule un
mariage qui s'apprête à défrayer les
manchettes celui de la nièce des frères
goutta trois hommes d'affaires
originaires de l'aide qui ont fait
fortune en afrique du sud
une fortune qui les rendra attrayant
pour les compagnies d'avions d'affaires
comme bombardier très rapidement ils
sont passés d'une petite compagnie
d'informatique à une entreprise en fait
je dirais plus groupes criminels
organisés qui avaient accès à des
centaines de millions de dollars de
contrats publics au state contre de
l'argent qui aurait servi à payer pour
ce mariage extravagants des célébrations
sur cinq jours qui se sont tenues dans
un décor presque décadent dans ce champ
feu d'artifice spectacle et surtout des
centaines d'invités qui auraient
bénéficié de passe droit en atterrissant
sur la base militaire de pretoria et
échapper au contrôle des autorités
grâce aux frères gupta on parle ici
d'une famille qui est un amant a obtenu
l'autorisation de faire atterrir ses
invités vip sur une base militaire
le pays est devenu complètement fou
c'était énorme
ça a mis en lumière à quel point les
gupta était devenu puissant
depuis un moment déjà la presse
soupçonne les frères et jean à toul et
tony gupta de corruption et d'avoir la
mainmise sur le gouvernement de jacob
zuma le mariage devient le symbole de
leur influence et fait l'objet de
parodies l'avais choisi je peux
catégoriquement affirmé sur la foi de
mes recherches qu'à partir de 2013
il était impossible pour une entreprise
d'ignorer que les goupes tables étaient
des personnes exposées à la corruption
leurs liens avec le gouvernement était
connu et dangereux et donc faire affaire
avec lui était une mauvaise décision
d'affaires
pourtant à peine dix mois après le
mariage bombardier courtise les gupta
pour leur vendre global enquête a eu
accès aux gouttes alix une fuite de
documents dans laquelle se trouvent des
milliers de courriels des frères gupta
il révèle l'étendue de leur influence
sur le gouvernement zuma
il compte elle aussi des dizaines de
courriels entre bombardier et les frères
gupta il révèle notamment que dès le
début 2014
bombardier semble avoir conscience qu'il
ya des risques à s'associer aux gupta au
directeur fait mention de leurs
connexions politiques
ces courriels montrent aussi comment par
la suite
bombardier 6 des liens avec les gupta
pour leur vendre global 6000 le
directeur des ventes pour l'afrique et
le moyen-orient s'adresse
personnellement aux frères gupta il les
remercie pour leur hospitalité
après avoir été reçus à leur résidence
il leur envoie des échantillons de
couleurs des bois et des cuirs on n'a
pas affaire ici à un simple porte parole
ou adjani la préposée au café on parle
ici de personnes à la tête de la
division afrique et moyen-orient
des gens qui se rapporte directement à
la haute direction de la compagnie
quatre à cinq fois par année
le même directeur des ventes se rend
aussi à l'usiné de dorval tran des
photos de l'appareil et les envoie au
groupe da [ __ ] up aux plaques fait
partie des premiers journalistes qui ont
pu consulter les gouttes alix dans son
esprit ça ne fait aucun doute
bombardier a servi d'intermédiaire
auprès d'une société d'état exportation
et développement canada edc qui relève
du gouvernement fédéral acceptera de
prêter 41 millions de dollars aux google
pour acheter l'avion bombardier à
faciliter ces transactions c'est
vraiment clair free courriel c'est ça le
problème
les multinationales moins scrupuleuses
en matière d'anti se sont précipités en
afrique du sud comme des prédateurs sur
bombardier le décès ne font pas
exception à genève en juin dernier
bombardier s'est défendu de manquer de
rigueur dans ces vérifications de sa
clientèle nos vérifications qui peuvent
inclure un background criminelle et
surtout beaucoup de listes de terrorisme
ou toute autre activité illégale quand
ça fait partie du processus il est très
robuste il est appliqué à plusieurs
points de la vente
donc ça fait partie des critères avant
signé un contrat absolue nous avons
voulu questionner bombardier pour avoir
des explications sur les niveaux de
risque pris par la compagnie et que nos
recherches ont révélé bombarder a refusé
nous accorder une nouvelle entrevue à la
caméra la multinationale qui délivrait
plus d'une centaine d'avions par année
affirme qu'il s'agit de cas isolés
nous n'avons pas accès à toutes les
ventes faites par bombardier souvent à
des sociétés offshore mais nous avons
également recensé des contrats cie
proche du président vladimir poutine des
oligarques russes qui se trouve
aujourd'hui sur une liste de sanctions
des états unis et de l'union européenne
si elles ne sont plus des citoyens
corporatifs idéal bain peut-être que
cela légitimité devient fragilisés comme
la professeur d'éthique jouer martin all
enseigne dans ses cours ou aux études
commerciales
la décision de tracer une ligne au
risque de perdre des ventes en évitant
certains clients toxiques relèvent
essentiellement de la gouvernance et des
valeurs des dirigeants l'opinion
publique est de plus en plus critique
par rapport à bandar t-il et puis c'est
normal parce que c'est une entreprise
qui est qui est aimé des québécois elle
est financée à travers nos impôts c'est
une entreprise on la décrit souvent
comme étant un fleuron de notre économie
et c'est normal qu'elles soient scrutés
c'est normal qu'on s'attende à plus de
bombardier bombardier à bien son code
d'éthique et de conduite
il est affiché sur son site web la
première valeur de l'entreprise
l'intégrité
nous agissons de manière intègre et
conforme à l'éthique en tout temps afin
de mériter et de préserver la confiance
et le respect des clients des
actionnaires des fournisseurs des
collègues des partenaires et des
collectivités mais à la lumière des
exemples que nous avons trouvé les
experts et les observateurs que nous
avons consultés se questionne sur le
respect de bombardier de ses propres
valeurs
leurs excuses et de dire oui on ne peut
pas baser nos décisions sur des rumeurs
mais c'est justement ça le critère quand
on doit décider si on fait affaire avec
des personnes exposées à la corruption
pas besoin d'avoir une décision du
tribunal
c'est une question de réputation roth
c'est vrai que c'est pas ce ne sont pas
des cons très puissant les gars ce sont
des contraintes qui sont moral
c'est-à-dire se sont dit on demande aux
organisations d'être responsable et
intègre au delà de la loi
est ce que le fait de les vertueux de
respecter un certain engagement éthique
peut conduire parfois à diminuer ses
profits planétaire la réponse est oui
de retour à genève bombardier elle mise
sur ses global pour assurer son avenir
ses concurrents aussi sont agressifs nos
recherches dans les groupe talix révèle
que l'américaine gulfstream tentaient
aussi de vendre gupta son avion haut de
gamme
l'équivalent américain de dc leur avait
même accordé le financement de 37
millions de dollars américain cessna a
également tenté de leur vendre un avion
on veut toujours avant plus qu'à des
avions les organisations sont poussés
vers la croissance et c'est bien mais
cette croissance là où elle doit être
limitée contre un contrôle et grands si
gilles tous les ans il ya un peu plus
d'un an le président zuma a finalement
quitté ses fonctions
croulant sous des allégations de
corruption la même journée la résidence
des gupta a été perquisitionné par
l'escouade anticorruption
mais les frères gupta eux ont disparu
fui le pays
l'avion que bombardier leur a vendu est
aussi introuvable pendant plusieurs
semaines un des ses adieux intenter des
poursuites judiciaires pour le récupérer
le global est réapparu à johannesbourg
en avril dernier
il est maintenant cloués au sol edc et
tente de le revendre pour récupérer
l'argent canadien qui a servi à financer
l'achat des gupta et qui de fait
c'est envoyé
[Musique]